well we have to start today with the
little red wave that couldn't what was
that kid's Story the The Little Engine
That Could This was very much the
opposite this ended up being the little
red wave that was a ripple so small that
Democrats may actually gain seats in the
Senate Democrats have won the Senate yes
we do not yet know the results of the
house we're going to talk uh on the
bonus show about the specific scenarios
that could end up prevailing in the
house but over in the Senate it is over
in the sense that Democrats have indeed
secured a majority the question now
becomes is it a 50 50 majority with
Kamala Harris as the tie-breaking vote
or is it a 5149 majority which would be
very important
if we want to make Joe manchin
irrelevant and we are going to get to
that but the final numbers uh in the
Nevada Senate race coming in over the
weekend as well as the calling of the
Arizona race and this is how Democrats
got to 50. Mark Kelly did defeat Blake
Masters in Arizona there is still six
percent of the vote to be counted there
but with Kelly's lead of over 125 000
votes it has been called this is really
great news for the country when it comes
to being marginally less humiliated on
an international stage Blake Masters the
Challenger to Mark Kelly the man who won
the Republican primary an absolute
humiliation just a pathetic embarrassing
horrible candidate didn't make any sense
from the extreme magowing almost as bad
as Carrie Lake quite frankly and we'll
get to Kerry Lake don't worry we have
plenty on Kerry Lake coming up a little
bit later that was number 49
uh we have in Georgia as we will talk
about Rafael Warnock and Herschel Walker
December 6th there will be a runoff much
of our focus and attention and resources
are going to go there and number 50
indeed from the state of Nevada where
Cortez masto the Democratic incumbent
has come out ahead of Challenger Adam
laxalt it is a 6500 vote lead with 98 in
it has been called there is not a 50
rule in the state of Nevada remember
that in Georgia there is a runoff
because of Georgia law that says the
winner must get 50 of the vote
in Nevada there is no such law and with
48.8 percent of the vote Cortez masto is
number 50 and Democrats have won the
Senate now there is going to be all
sorts of after the fact armchair
quarterbacking prognostication
reprognostication whatever the case may
be a couple of story lines that are
coming up and some of them I've dealt
with myself on Twitter which by the way
is barely functional anymore under Elon
Musk Twitter is quite frankly a disaster
at this point let's put that aside
um some of you coming forward and saying
even to me sir you were wrong about the
coming Red Wave you were you need to
apologize as usual some in my audience
obsessed with me even though I have
nothing to do with this let's review
what had been my message in the last
three to four weeks going into this
election I told you
the momentum has shifted in the
direction of Republicans the momentum
has shifted that being said many
individual races when you look at their
average polling have a bunch of
right-leaning polls included in them and
it is making me and others suspect that
some of these forecasts which include
these right-leaning polls May overstate
the degree of of momentum in the
direction of Republicans and in the last
week I very specifically said
whatever is the truth about these polls
it's over the polls are a tool earlier
on to give us a sense of the direction
and momentum when we are seven five
three one day away from the election
if the polls are right or the polls are
wrong we have to go and vote and thanks
to a lot of 18 to 20 or 29 year olds
which we will talk about a little bit
later the Red Wave was at most a red
Ripple we will see what happens in the
house very very soon but Democrats will
control the Senate now the question is
50 or 51. we talk about it all the time
one of the biggest contributors to
climate change is deforestation did you
know that 15 of deforestation is due to
toilet paper production alone according
to the nrdc that's why I love our
sponsor real paper real paper makes a
sustainable toilet paper no trees it
uses 100 bamboo a bamboo stock can keep
being harvested indefinitely no
deforestation real paper is certified by
the forest Stewardship Council for
responsible harvesting of the bamboo
grass used for their paper another
contributor to climate change the
plastic that the toilet paper comes
wrapped in that's why real paper
involves no plastic packaging and best
of all real paper looks and feels just
like normal traditional toilet paper the
cost is similar it is fantastic on their
website you can do a one-time purchase
or set up an easy recurring subscription
the way that I did my audience gets 30
off your first order plus free shipping
go to realpaper.com Pacman and use the
code Pacman at checkout the link is down
below